eventually if you work through many of
these you will catch a glimpse of
this that which is beautiful in itself
not beautiful because something else has
made it so everything trickles
down in this this hierarchy from the top
downward but you have to go as a human
being you have to go up this ladder you
can't just jump to well you know let's
say you hear this lecture you're like
yeah beautiful itself hell I'm going to
skip all this intermediary
nonsense just give me that Dr Sandler if
Plato is right you would actually have
to spend some time learning well you
probably don't need to spend a lot of
time learning how to love bodies and
then learning how to love souls learning
how to love laws and institutions
learning how to love knowledge for for
its own sake and then seeing something
Beyond knowledge itself